I don't read about myself I really
genuinely don't well
this cover is definitely worth a read
mila kunis stuns on the front of Cosmos
August issue and inside she opens up
about dealing with the constant
speculation surrounding her personal
life especially when it comes to her
relationship with husband ashton kutcher
quote i genuinely don't know what's
written about me other than I know that
I'm pregnant about once a year and my
husband and I are getting a divorce once
a year mostly everything that you hear
about me is a rumor you know sometimes
somewhere truth will sneak in very well
very very early and the 34 year old
actress admits that sometimes the fake
stories do have real-life consequences
my parents and my grandparents sometimes
get confused at one point when I was
pregnant the tabloids said that I had an
emergency and was rushed to the hospital
and my face was on the cover the amount
of stress that caused my family nobody
will understand still some of those fake
reports give Kunis's family hope she
says her dad is pushing for a third
grandchild quote my dad is always very
hopeful that the pregnancies are true
he's always like is there really another
listen I'm not no I'm not pregnant oh my
god this is like this is that rumor
start
[Music]
[Applause]